Ist denn jetzt schon Weihnachten? Nein, noch nicht ganz. Morgen ist zumindest schon mal Heiligabend und wir können alle die Geschenke abholen. Wolfgang und ich, wir dachten uns, wir beschenken euch heute mit einem öffentlichen Teil des ansonsten streng abgeriegelten Salons. Bevor wir Branko Milanović Buch ausführlich besprechen, haben Wolfgang und ich uns jeweils drei Thesen vorgestellt, mit denen wir in das Buch reinwechseln. Vieles entsteht natürlich erst im Gespräch, wie zum Beispiel diese Erkenntnis, dass der ganze MAGA America First Isolationismus eigentlich nur Plan B ist. Wenn es mit dem Imperialismus nicht mehr funktioniert, dann versucht man sowas. Bei so einem Buch machen solche Exkurse richtig Spaß. Es wird einem vieles erklärt. Zumindest die kleinen Fragen, die wir uns gegenseitig stellen, wollen wir euch hier heute schon mal schenken. Auch für den Weg nach Hause natürlich. Man sitzt jetzt im Zug, der fährt nicht, man langweilt sich. Also kann man Podcast hören. Die Neuen Zwanziger sind da natürlich an eurer Seite.
Dieser Podcast wird unterstützt von Procon. Was ist Procon? Procon ist eine Energiegenossenschaft. Wir wissen Genossenschaften, da schließen sich Bürger zusammen, um ein großes Ziel zu verfolgen und es gemeinsam zu erreichen. Und bei einer Energiegenossenschaft liegt der Zweck meist entweder in der Energieerzeugung oder im Handel von Energie. Es gibt sehr viele Energiegenossenschaften in Deutschland. Und Procon ist eine besonders große Genossenschaft. 40.000 Mitglieder vertreten es Procon in Deutschland, Polen, Finland und Spanien. Procon setzt auf Wind onshore, auf Speichertechnologien, PV und Biomethan. Und mit dem Kauf von Genossenschaftsanteilen liefern die Mitglieder wichtiges Eigenkapital für den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien. Bereits mit 50 Euro kann jeder Mitglied werden und somit dann ein bisschen die Energiewende selbst in die Hand nehmen. Man kann natürlich auch Mitgliedschaften verschenken.
Ja, und wenn das nicht mal eine gute Idee ist, an jemanden, der schon alles hat, während man selber nicht mal eine gute Geschenkidee hat, dieses Jahr einfach ein ganzes Windrad verschenken. Ihr habt dann Anteile an Procon, wenn ihr für 50 Euro da einsteigt. Euch gehört genauso viel Stimmrecht über die Windräder wie jedem anderen der 40.000 Mitglieder. Egal, wie viel man reinbringt, die anderen holen nur mehr Rendite raus. Aber ihr seid genauso Teil dieser sehr großen Gemeinschaft mit einer sehr guten Idee. Und ihr könnt damit richtig auftrumpfen und pralen. Stellt euch vor, wie ihr unterm Weihnachtsbaum sitzt, der und der Onkel erfährt, dass er ein Windrad bekommt. Da erspart sich auch jede andere Diskussion über, wer ist hier der Beste. Das ist die Idee, die wir gerne weitertragen. Wir danken Procon sehr dafür, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Also auch euch.
Und man hat natürlich als Mitglied dann auch Zugang zu vergünstigtem Strom. Und in den letzten Jahren wurden erfolgsabhängige Dividenden in Höhe von 3 bis 5 Prozent ausgezahlt. Es kann sich also lohnen.
Alle Informationen zu Procon in unseren Shownotes, also greift mal in eure Hosentasche. Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Ich habe in unserem Buch einiges zu Marx gelesen. Überdenkst du deine Lektüre von Marx nochmal?
Ich würde sie erweitern.
Was heißt erweitern?
Nun ja, deine These ist, dieses Buch sagt uns, Marx hat Unrecht oder was?
Also ich möchte es ganz explizit wie folgt sagen, nachdem ich dieses Buch ausführlich studiert habe und überrascht war, es war ja deine Empfehlung.
Ja.
Und ich dachte mir so, ah ja, hier kommt ja auch Marx drin vor. Also es liegt irgendwie nahe. Ich kannte Branko Milanović, obwohl du den vorher immer mal erwähnt hattest, nicht lesend. Und muss doch jetzt sagen, diese ganze große Idee von Marx, dass auf den Kapitalismus zwangsläufig der Sozialismus folgt, geht vielleicht gar nicht auf. Und Milanović schreibt so darüber, dass er sein eigenes Argument abschließt mit, und es würde auch Marx heute so sehen.
Ja, die Sache ist ja die, dass Marx gar nicht so sehr eine Zwangsläufigkeit sah. Also es wird kommen. Ja, dann muss man ja nur warten. Dann hätte man ja auch gar nicht über revolutionäre Subjekte oder so nachdenken müssen über eine Arbeiterklasse, sondern dann warten wir ab. Und irgendwann schlägt die Uhr zwölf und dann ist der Sozialismus da. Sondern es ist ja die Frage, ob der Kapitalismus ein Stadium schafft, von dem aus der Sozialismus möglich ist. Und wenn ich gerade diese kleine Abzweigung machen darf, es gibt ja von Branko Milanović noch das Buch Kapitalism Global. Und dort erzählt er ja, wie der Sozialismus im zwanzigsten Jahrhundert eine wichtige historische Funktion hatte. Nämlich eine kontraintuitive. Wir würden ja auch sagen, aha, der Sozialismus entwickelt sich aus dem Kapitalismus. Die These ist ja relativ leicht zu verstehen. Die Produktivkräfte werden entfesselt. Wir haben heute, das betonen wir hier laufend, einen unglaublichen stofflichen Reichtum. Nur kommt er ganz häufig bei denen, die ein Bedürfnis danach haben, nicht an, weil sie kein Geld in der Hand haben, um das entsprechende zu kaufen. Aber eigentlich sind wir uns ja einig, zum Beispiel jetzt für Deutschland oder für ganz Europa gesprochen oder für den Westen müsste kein Kind hungern. Man sagt nicht, ja leider haben wir zu wenige Äpfel, deswegen gibt es keine für die Kinder, sondern wir haben Leute, die sehr viel Geld haben und Leute, die haben wenig Geld. Die Idee ist also, wenn diese Produktivkräfte so entfesselt sind, dann kann man eigentlich sie irgendwann in die Hände der Arbeiter nehmen oder sie ergreifen sie sich und dann kann man die Wirtschaft so organisieren, dass man nach den Bedürfnissen produziert und da ein Reich der Freiheit schafft, dass so ein Kapitalismus nicht möglich ist. Die historische Entwicklung aber war folgende und das ist etwas, wo Branko Milanović noch mal Bezug drauf nimmt, und das ist, dass der Sozialismus diente in 20. Jahrhundert dazu, dass in den noch feudal organisierten Gesellschaften plötzlich eine Revolution stattfand. Und diese Revolution hat die feudalen Verhältnisse abgeschafft. Da wurden dann die Könige geköpft oder was auch immer oder der Zar. Und das hatte aber nicht dazu geführt, dass der Sozialismus sich dauerhaft etablierte, sondern man hat durch den Sozialismus dann die Produktivkräfte entfaltet, hat stofflichen Reichtum geschaffen und dann hat der Kapitalismus übernommen. Das heißt, der Sozialismus wurde zur Brücke für den Kapitalismus. Jetzt gibt es aber eine neue Entwicklung, nämlich dass wir eine Klasse haben, die nicht nur Vermögen hat und reine Rentierdaseins führt, wie wir das aus dem 19. Jahrhundert kennen. Denken wir an Jane Austen, Romane, da sitzen die da, sind Pächter von irgendwas. Wir wissen gar nicht so genau, wo kommt das ganze Geld her? Jedenfalls arbeiten die nie. Die machen nie einen Finger krumm. Und jetzt haben wir so eine neue Klasse, die viel Geld hat, geerbt durch Vermögen und auch noch viel Geld verdient. Also die sich absolut zur arbeitenden Bevölkerung sieht. Und diese Klasse hat Marx nicht sehen können, weil es auch nicht klar war, dass der Kapitalismus sich so entwickelt. Und Marx hat auch nicht sehen können, dass sich ein Wohlstand so global entfalten kann, dass plötzlich wir die Staaten in dieser Weise konkurrieren gegenüber haben, wie Milanović uns das jetzt hier beschreibt. Und das führt natürlich erstmal dazu, dass hier kein Weg für den Sozialismus offen ist.
Ja, also finde ich interessant, dass er sagt, Marx hätte mir zugestimmt, so wie ich über die Manager schreiben, den Managerialismus, also die managerial class, die wir von Kathrin Lu und so schon gehört haben und die sozusagen die großen Verwalter sind, die dieses Konkurrenzverhältnis der Staaten und so weiter für sich weiter ausnutzen. So ein bisschen wie, wenn das Family Office plötzlich sich einfach mit aufschwingt.
Ja.
Dann plötzlich damit machen.
Außerdem haben wir hier eine starke These, finde ich, über Nationalismus oder eine Aufforderung fast, einen Appell über Nationalismus nochmal neu nachzudenken. Du hast ja im Vorgespräch eben schon gesagt, Milanović interessiert sich nicht so allzu sehr für die konkreten Führerpersonen, die irgendwo politische Geschäfte führen, sondern die sind im Grunde austauschbar. Der Zeitgeist hat sie halt hervorgebracht. Und dann wird so ein bisschen deren Tagebuch in der Tagesschau erzählt. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so entscheidend. Und das gilt auch für große Ideen. Also er sagt, Nationalismus, ja, wächst aus der Gier der Einzelnen heraus. Und dann will man das halt beschützen, einen Zaun bauen, bevor die Nachbarn kommen und so. Und es ist jetzt gar nicht so ein großer politischer Wind, der weht, sondern es ist einfach eine ökonomische Ableitung. Da habe ich so gedacht, ja, das ist...
In der Tat.
Das ist fast wie die Systemtheorie, immer wieder zurückzuziehen auf körperliche Bedürfnisse, symbiotische Mechanismen. Wie genau ist der Körper, und zwar nicht als kognitive, sondern biologisches System an die Gesellschaft gekoppelt? Und irgendwie muss ich habe Hunger gesellschaftlich verrechnet werden. Und plötzlich haben wir einen Knappheitsdiskurs, der einfach Profite verrechnet und so weiter und so fort. Finde ich sehr gut. Eine These möchte ich noch vorher...
Wenn ich ja gerade noch anknüpfen kann. Das ist ja so interessant, dass hier nochmal der Nationalismus eigentlich auch entkernt wird. Also wir würden ja immer sagen, aber da gibt es doch dann so Föheton-Fragen nach dem Deutschen oder so. Und er würde sagen, naja, die einen holen sich das, die anderen das raus, was jetzt gerade funktioniert. Aber im Grunde kann man es runterrechnen. Will ich, dass der da im Nachbarland auch so reich ist wie ich? Weiß nicht.
Es ist jedenfalls, du hast jetzt entkernt, das ist genau die Einflugschneise, um zu erklären, ja, ja, das sind schon Ausländer. Aber die wählen halt trotzdem die AfD. Und man denkt sich so, ja, genau. Also warum auch nicht? Die haben ja auch was zu verteidigen. Die haben den Laden aufgemacht, die haben ihre Biografie hier gestaltet, das verteidigen die jetzt. Und da kommen halt irgendwelche armen Leute von irgendwo her. Und dann ist doch eine Syrer, der vor 20 Jahren hierhergezogen ist, völlig egal, ob jetzt in Äthiopien oder in Ghana, nach Deutschland kommt, der gehört hier nicht her.
Das ist nur so ein Diskurs aus Schnellroder, Benedikt Kaiser, der will noch mal gucken, wie deutsch ist denn hier jemand? Die Autortonen Deutschen oder wie das dann genannt wird, aber das interessiert sonst niemanden.
Und die werden dann plötzlich Notfall-Liebertär. Man denkt sich, was ist das für ein alberner Quatsch? Ich kann es nicht einfach sagen, dass es die pure Gier und der Ekel vor anderen Leuten ist. Und das war es. Also ganz elementare Gefühle. Außerdem, bevor wir hier groß einsteigen und du mir deine Vorab-Erkenntnisse, ich fand es sehr gut, wie der Milanović einfach Xi, Putin und Trump als Konterrevolutionäre darstellt.
Ja, ja.
Da lag was in der Luft. Männer wurden geboren. Sie waren gerade im richtigen Alter. Alt plus eins ist zwei. Jetzt zerbrecht euch nicht das Vöhtor-Gehirn darüber.
Ja, ist Trump da eine ganze Besonderheit? Er beschreibt noch mal so ein paar Dinge von Trump, die sehr gut sind. Darauf müssen wir noch mal kommen, wie er diese amerikanische Politikwirtschaftselite schildert und sagt, naja, war der jetzt wirklich so anders als ihr? Glaubt ihr das wirklich? Aber dass er die so in einem Atemzug nennt, könnte jetzt bei denen, die es nicht gelesen haben, vielleicht im Kopf auslösen, naja, genau, das sind ja alles drei Autokraten, aber das ist gar nicht so der Punkt bei Milanović jetzt, dass er sagt, das ist die Autokratie gegen die Demokratie, sondern er sagt, sie sind Konterevolutionäre bezogen auf die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung, nämlich, dass da eine neoliberale Elite entstanden ist, beziehungsweise eine Oligarchien-Elite oder eine korrupte Partei-Elite, gegen die man dann mit Rückhalt der Bevölkerung, also populistisch in diesem Sinne, plötzlich solche Figuren hatte aufsteigen sehen. Aber das sei nun einfach eine historische Entwicklung, die das genommen hat und nicht jetzt so ein Sonderfall Trump oder ein Sonderfall Putin, sondern wie du sagst, die waren eben dann zum rechten Zeitpunkt da.
Ja, dass man sich in ihn irren kann, ist eingepreist. Ja, also Trump wollte den Swamp drainen und den Deep State abschaffen und dass ich danach herausstellte, dass er das erst richtig etabliert hat, was man vorher kritisiert hat, ist halt so.
Ja.
Aber diese Verwechslung, die Wahl findet halt statt, wenn die Wahl stattfindet und nicht ein Jahr später, wo man das Retrospectiv alles anders sehen kann. Von daher ist das schon wahnsinnig klug.
Eine These, die ich mitnehme aus diesem Buch, ist, dass wir uns vor globaler Gleichheit eigentlich fürchten.
Das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, denn wir hatten jetzt erst wieder ein Herz-für-Kinder-Gala und so. Und das Jahresende ist ja eigentlich immer so ein Fall von, ja, den ganz Ärmsten helfen wir jetzt nochmal. Also wer jetzt nur fünf Euro hat, dem schenken wir nochmal fünf, dann hat er nämlich zehn. Das ist eine Verdopplung. So, und das gibt es ja auch im globalen Kontext. Also zum Jahresende freuen wir uns nochmal ganz doll, dass auf der anderen Seite der Welt ganz viele ganz Arme aus der Armut ein bisschen geholt werden. So, wenn diese Niveauveränderung aber woanders stattfindet. Ach so, die Leute, die vorher immer in Vietnam Urlaub gemacht haben, machen den jetzt bei mir in Thailand? Im Vier-Stern-Resort?
Nee.
Plötzlich fallen sie auf, ja. Und das ist natürlich...
Was, die Inder trinken jetzt auch mir den Champagner weg? Muss das denn sein?
Genau, also die Franzosen machen doch nur so und so viel. Das können wir doch nicht alles nach Indien schicken.
Ja.
Ja, aber die bezahlen mehr dafür. Wie, was, wo haben die das Geld her? So, ich wollte die doch nur aus der Armut holen, ja. Also das finde ich auch vielleicht für euch nicht das richtige Wort, ja.
Ja. Dann diese schon angesprochene Homo Plutia, also die zum reichsten Dezil gehören, also den reichsten zehn Prozent, von denen gibt es mehr und mehr Leute, die die reichsten Vermögenden sind und die reichsten Einkommensbezieher.
Also Homo, weil sie beides, gleichwertig Vermögen und Einkommen.
Und dass es dieses Phänomen jetzt gibt, also dass die Reichen auch arbeiten und zwar harte arbeiten.
Also ich würde sagen, nicht hart, aber viel und so auf gewisse Maße intensiv. Ja, sie genau, aber es ist nicht die harte Arbeit.
Es ist work hard, play hard im Sinne von dieser, wir gucken lieber noch mal eine Runde und machen auch den freitag Abend durch, bis in den Samstag.
Man pendelt auch nur von Millionenstadt zu Millionenstadt.
Klar.
Fliegt auch nur fürs Glas und so.
Man fasst sonst nichts an außer die Tastatur. Das ist wirklich klar. Aber dass diese Homo Plutier eigentlich Umverteilung nahezu verunmöglicht, weil man ja relativ leicht sagen kann, das ist ja leistungsloses Einkommen bei den Vermietern. Aber wenn jetzt dann so eine Kaste ist, die auch wirklich arbeitet und eine 80-Stunden-Woche hat, kann die sich viel besser abdichten vor diesen Umverteilungsdiskursen.
Genau. Und Abdichtung ist genau das Wort. Also du hast die Zahlen ja eben schon genannt. Ich will sie hier nochmal wiederholen. Es ist wirklich sehr beeindruckend. Denn normale Menschen machen die Erfahrung, okay, die Auswahl fürs Gymnasium kriegen Eltern noch irgendwie geregelt. Aber das Kind dann wirklich durchs Abitur zu bringen und dann noch durchs Jurastudium und zwar an den drei Top-Unis der Welt und so, das kostet. Und zwar pro Kind 10 Millionen Dollar. Die einfach als private Investition, um danach die hunderten Millionen und Milliarden weiter zu schützen. Muss man das Kind dann doch, also das Kind muss schon das Jurastudium einmal wirklich machen.
Ja.
Es ist eben nicht das aristokratische Wir schlendern einfach durch Südengland und so, sondern nein, nein, also die Zugangsbeschränkungen sind hart. Wir hatten die Skandale in Amerika mit, wie das mit den Unis ist und wer dann nochmal so alles als Sportler eingeschrieben wird in Harvard und so, damit es irgendwie hinhaut. Und das Preisschild lautet 10 Millionen pro Kind.
Ja. Er schreibt hier, dass die monetäre Elite selbst gut gebildet und auch hardworking, also intensiv arbeitend, einen ganz großen Teil des Geldes ausgeben kann oder generell ein Berggeld ausgeben kann für die Erziehung und Bildung der Kinder, damit diese sich in diesem elitären System durchsetzen. Er sagt, Meritokratie ist nur ein anderer Weg, um eine herrschende Klasse herzustellen. Da geht es dann nicht mehr um den Geburtsvorteil, dass man einen großen Namen trägt. Das kann mitunter auch helfen. Aber wichtig ist wirklich, dass man educational credentials hat, dass man also Zertifikate hat, die man vorzeigen kann. Harvard, Columbia, Down-Dort, Praktikum gemacht.
Irgendwas in Tokio.
Was auch immer. Das sammelt man alles. Und er sagt dann, und hier kommt er wieder mit Marx, also er ist ja nicht ein Anti-Marxist, sondern er liest ja Marx wahnsinnig produktiv und sagt, na ja, von Marx gibt es doch dieses GWG-Strich. Also das heißt, man hat Geld und das investiert man, dann macht man eine Ware. Ja, in Maschinen oder in Kinder.
Jetzt in Kinder, aber bei Marx hat es Maschinen.
Und dann bekommt man mehr raus. Und so lohnen sich auch diese 10 Millionen. Und er sagt dann ja, also diese 10 Millionen kommen so zustande, dass er vergleicht den Unterschied zwischen der normalen Mittelklasse, was die investieren kann in den Kindern und das, was die reichen investieren. Da sind wir bei 10 Millionen Differenz angekommen. Das heißt, das ist nahezu uneinholbar.
Es gibt von Thomas Tom Krebs diese Forschung, die ich ja in der Kinderwüste auch gleich auf Seite eins unterbringe, die wir bei Philippa Siegel-Klöckner im Buch gelesen haben. Eine Investition in Bildung rentiert sich mit 14 Prozent nach elf Jahren. Das Kind kommt nur Arbeitsmarkt an und bringt viel höhere Einkommenssteuergewinne für den Staat mit, als wenn man jetzt ein Need ist, der erstmal aufgepäppelt werden muss. Philippa Siegel-Klöckner übrigens, spektakuläre Instagram-Videos immer wieder zu diesem, sie bringt eine Bildungsstudie nach der anderen und bringt die innerhalb von 30 Sekunden mit der deutschen Volkswirtschaft in Verbindung. Und dadurch wird einem sofort Angst und Bange. Und das große Problem, das habe ich auch mit Humann und Mary besprochen, als Humann so die Nachfrage hatte, warum investieren wir das Geld nicht einfach, warum so viele Rendite? Und das große Problem ist, weil wir sie particularistisch nicht verrechnen können. Alle Deutschen müssen in alle Kinder investieren, damit es allen Deutschen gut geht. Aber das eigene Kind könnte trotzdem unter die Räder kommen dabei. Ja, so. Hier haben wir diese ultimative Bestätigung, dass diese Bildungsrendite tatsächlich da ist und auch radikal knallhart durchgesetzt wird, wenn man sie particular verrechnet, wenn es in der eigenen Familie bleibt. 10 Millionen für das eigene Kind, um später hunderte Millionen und Milliarden zu bewahren. So, da sagt sich jede Familie, die eine Milliarde auf dem Konto hat, also diese 10 Millionen bezahle ich auf jeden Fall. So, da organisiere ich sogar noch. Das lasse ich nicht Family Office machen, sondern da habe ich meine eigenen. So, da gucke ich drauf, was passiert. So, und das können wir auch volkswirtschaftlich machen. Diese Superreichen haben an diesem Punkt Recht. Wir sollten von ihnen lernen. Und diese Bildungsrendite für uns alle fruchtbar machen. Und ja, das ist das erste Buch, in dem das so drin steht. Also, das ist einfach validiert so. Es sind echte 14 Prozent. Man muss sie nur einmal reinstecken, dann kommt man sie auch hinten wieder raus. Aber man muss es machen.
Jetzt werde ich dich noch mit einer These konfrontieren. Ich bin gespannt, was du dazu sagst. Haben wir uns oder nein, ich formuliere es wirklich als These, wir haben uns in den vergangenen Jahren zu viel über Vermögen unterhalten und zu wenig über Einkommen gesprochen.
Widerspruch. Widerspruch aus einfachem Grunde. Der Genie-Koeffizient beim Vermögen ist 0,8. Statistisch gerundet hat in Deutschland eine Person alles und 80 Millionen haben nichts. Statistisch gerundet im Sinne von so ungefähr 150 Familien haben alles, und der Rest hat nichts. Beim Einkommen ist der Genie-Koeffizient 0,3.
Ja, ich weiß.
Und zwischen 0,3 und 0,8 liegen dramatische Welten, die ja auch Branko Milanović nicht leugnet. Wir haben dieses neue Phänomen, dass die Superreichen noch mal einen Weg gefunden haben, ihren Superreichtum abzusichern über ihren Nachwuchs und diese Bildungsinvestition. Das heißt, diese jungen Leute treten an zu durchschauen und verstehen zu wollen, was mit dem Geld geschieht. Sie sind selber diejenigen, die mit diesem Vermögen arbeiten. Sie lagern das nicht an eine Vermögensverwaltung, an einem Family-Office aus. Sie arbeiten also. Dadurch generieren sie auch Einkommen. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass deswegen, ja, nur weil die auch mal so ein Jahreseinkommen von 10 Millionen einfahren, während die Familie selbst 40 Milliarden hat, dass wir deswegen jetzt zu viel auf Vermögen und zu wenig auf Einkommen haben.
So meinte ich es auch nicht. Also es gibt dieses Phänomen Homopletie, und es wird auch sich zeigen, ob sich das weiterhin so entwickelt. Noch ist es ja nicht so, dass es gänzlich so ist in dem obersten Deziel. Das macht er auch deutlich und er beschreibt es ja auch für fortgeschrittene kapitalistische Länder. Er zeigt zum Beispiel auch auf, dass das in Mexiko nicht in dieser Weise der Fall ist oder auch in anderen Ländern nicht so stark da ist. Da meinte ich es gar nicht. Aber wir haben unglaublich viele Videos auf Instagram gesehen, Texte, Rich und all das. Ich bin ja auch grundsätzlich dafür. Ich finde es manchmal noch viel zu zahm formuliert alles. Nur um das schon mal klarzustellen, also ich sage jetzt nicht, ach, jetzt lassen wir doch mal den Reichen das Vermögen. Nein, ich glaube aber, indem wir so sehr über diese großen Vermögensberge gesprochen haben, ist uns eigentlich ein anderer Punkt nicht aufgefallen. Nämlich Umverteilung findet ja auch dann statt, wenn ich höhere Löhne einfordere. Und die findet vielleicht auf bessere Weise statt, weil sie im Portemonnaie der Arbeitnehmer landet. Während eine Umverteilung, die jetzt Erbschaftssteuer oder so was bedeutet, erst mal sagt, die Staatskasse bekommt mehr Geld. Wer weiß, was die damit anstellen. Ich bin generell auch für diese Umverteilung, glaube nur, dass wenn wir jetzt einmal diese Brille aufziehen, die Branko Milanović uns reicht, dann geht es ja wirklich darum, dass es ja seinen Stecken fährt, eben nicht wie PKT Vermögen zu vergleichen, sondern Arbeitseinkommen zu vergleichen. Und diese Arbeitseinkommen im internationalen Vergleich bringen uns eigentlich in die Präduje, wie eben schon angekündigt, dass wir uns davor fürchten, dass andere zu reich werden. Wir aber plötzlich auch nicht mehr so ganz einfach sagen können, naja, diese Superreichen, die haben diese unglaublichen Vermögensberge, da müssen wir mal ran. Sondern wir müssen auch, wenn wir in einem globalen Verhältnis sehen, eigentlich ganz hart noch mal uns selbst befragen, sind wir nicht im Grunde erbitterte Nationalisten? Dass wir sagen, oh Gott, bevor jetzt wirklich mehr Chinesen so reich sind wie reiche Westler, müssen wir irgendwas dagegen tun, weil ich möchte jetzt nicht plötzlich im Urlaub oder beim Ticketkauf für das nächste Taylor Swift-Konzert oder so mit anderen Reichen noch konkurrieren, die dazugekommen sind. Beziehungsweise, wir haben ja so viel darüber gesprochen, wo steht man wirtschaftlich, ist eine Frage von Relation. Und auch da zeigt er uns ja, dass wir mit unseren Reallöhnen in Deutschland mal ganz oben in der Welt standen. Und das höchste war, glaube ich, 1992. Und wie sich das alles jetzt relativiert, damit werden auch Produkte teurer. Die Frage ist also, wird man in zehn Jahren noch sich als Facharbeiter ein iPhone leisten können oder nicht mehr? Ist das dann einfach außer der Welt? Diese Fragen stellen sich da. Und womit ich nicht sagen will, wir vergessen jetzt die Vermögensungleichheit. Aber ich glaube, wir müssen viel mehr den Fokus auf die Einkommen richten, weil man doch darüber nochmal mehr aussagen kann, als wenn man einfach nur sagt, ja, da gibt es Leute, die haben ganz, ganz viel Geld. Aber dann kann man sich sehr schön aus der Gleichung rausnehmen.
Jetzt kommt ein Kicker-Argument, geradezu ein Stunt von mir. Ich habe ja bislang sehr, sehr, sehr häufig über Erbschaftssteuer geredet und eigentlich nie über Vermögenssteuer.
Ja.
Ich habe einmal über Vermögenssteuer geredet, als wir im Sommersalon drauf zu sprechen kamen, dass ja die Vermögenssteuer ausgesetzt wurde als Veronica Grimm usw. Und ich sagte, nee, nee, die wurde ausgesetzt, weil die Grundstück- und Immobilienpreise vom Verfassungsgericht damals als, nee, die müssen neu bewertet werden. Die werden zum Teil Faktor 10 zu billig verrechnet. Ich finde, jetzt haben wir eine neue Grundsteuerreform, die jetzt auch juristisch durch ist, sozusagen durchs Verfassungsgericht. Also wir können jetzt durchaus sagen, wir haben jetzt wieder eine Bewertungsgrundlage. Also wir können die Vermögenssteuer wieder aktivieren. Aber Achtung, These, die Erbschaftssteuer ist eine Einkommenssteuer.
Inwiefern?
Derjenige, der das Erbe entgegen nimmt, berechnet es bei sich als Einkommen.
Ja.
Und dann ist das ein Einkommenssteuersatz.
Konnte man so machen.
So. Und von daher deine These, wir haben zu wenig über Einkommen und zu viel über Vermögen. Ich sage, nee, die Erbschaftssteuer war immer eine Einkommenssteuer. Also ist immer eine Einkommenssache gewesen. Also sozusagen einfach nur im intergenerationalen Diskurs ist es halt eine Einkommensversteuerung.
The Great Global Transformation ist ja erstmal ein Buch, das so klingt, als ginge es hier um Geopolitik, tut es auch. Aber es ist ein anderer Ansatz, nämlich sich auf die Zahlen zu konzentrieren bei den Einkommen. Wie haben sich da die Volkswirtschaften entwickelt? Wo sind sie gewachsen, gefallen? Es ist ein Mensch, Branko Milanović, der in Relationen denkt. Und wenn wir über Ungleichheit nachdenken, das muss man nochmal betonen, auch wenn es eine Binsenweisheit ist, ist ja völlig klar, dass wir immer relational denken müssen. Bin ich genauso reich, wenn ich in BMW fahre und mein Nachbar hat ein BMW? Eigentlich könnte man sagen, oder wenn ich in BMW fahre und mein Nachbar kann nur einen Golf fahren. Macht das einen Unterschied? Weil ich fahre ja immer noch den BMW. Aber fühle ich mich ein bisschen besser, wenn das so ist, wenn es diese diese Clouff gibt. Und das ist eigentlich eine Kernfrage, die jetzt Branko Milanović aber nicht so anthropologisch aufmacht. Am Ende ein bisschen, das finde ich auch, da ist die einzige Schwäche im Buch. Aber er will tatsächlich das auf die einzelnen Nationen sehen. Fühlt man sich ein bisschen schlechter, wenn die anderen ein bisschen besser werden. Und wir hatten mal vor vielen, vielen Monaten einen Landsprecht-Podcast. Da hatte Precht dieses Wort Subkutan, das sich in Deutschland viele als absteigend erleben. Also was einmal die Realität doch ist. Aber es ist so Subkutan etwas da, das hier etwas verrutscht in der gesamten Welt. Und dieses Subkutane, das Unterschwellige, wenn man so möchte, wird hier jetzt nach oben gespült von Branko Milanović, weil er die Statistiken zur Hand hat und sie lesen kann.
Ja, also schon der Einstieg ins Buch macht für mich als Neukunde von Branko Milanović, um die ökonomische Diktion gleich mal zu verwenden, also ich hab das erste Mal im Buch von ihm gelesen. Und dann wird es ja gleich superdeutlich, man wird es ein bisschen an die Hand genommen. Achtung, Achtung, lieber Leser, hier geht es um das große Bild, das große rote Faden. Es gibt also drei globale Veränderungen, die er uns vorstellt.
Das war erst der Teaser, in dem wir uns mit jeweils drei Thesen aus dem sensationellen Buch The Great Global Transformation von Branko Milanović konfrontieren. Anschließend diskutieren wir rund zweieinhalb Stunden über dieses sensationelle Buch. Danach gibt es wie immer Empfehlungen. Gute Artikel, gute Bücher, das alles zusammen gibt es, wenn man den Salon abonniert, über Apple, Patreon und Steady. Außerdem kann man über Steady den Salon auch für ein Jahr verschenken. Wer also noch ein Weihnachtsgeschenk sucht, wird vielleicht dort fündig. Wir wünschen viel Vergnügen mit dem neuen Salon.